[Music]
so y'all know that I have something
called the citizens of Joe Mallya
private Facebook legacy the IBM I'm a
member
I'm not we have a question here from
Bianca sunny ninja carbajal hey did
anyone ever deal with imposter syndrome
feeling that everything they get in life
is only because they are lucky and they
didn't really do anything special to get
it you doubt your own accomplishments
and feel like you're going to be exposed
as a fraud Wow
yes is a very okay so impostor syndrome
is basically a psychological pattern in
which one doubts one's accomplishment
and has a persistent internalized fear
of being exposed as fraud right yeah so
it's like you're it's like it's like
it's like you feel like you don't
deserve the success so you don't deserve
where you're at and you feel like one
day someone's gonna call you out as a
straight Fink I honestly think
everyone's a fraud that's my that's the
benefit of me what do you mean by that
everyone feels everyone's full of [ __ ]
they don't everyone doesn't know what
the [ __ ] they're doing everyone makes
mistakes that part helps huge CEOs all
these big rich guys they make mistakes
they start businesses that fail like
everyone [ __ ] up I think that the
biggest frauds exactly nobody dude you
take the same director Steven Spielberg
who directed some of the most classic
movies and you look at this movie called
1942 or whatever is complete ass yes
thank you how is that possible though
it's because people [ __ ] up and like did
not everyone know the exact what they're
doing at all times this is a common
thing though I've heard this term being
thrown around like a lot of people say
um my last remember uh Stephanie miss
mango but mm-hmm
so she she told me in David that she
went through a huge thing of imposter
syndrome and I didn't realize that this
was such a big thing because I find out
she didn't really eat the food like she
doesn't deserve the success and all that
yeah she hates the food I did it was no
no
camera funny that like thinking you're
an imposter like did I eat that food I
know a fraud like that's what she's
impossible yeah what was some it was a
concept that I thought was a joke I
didn't take it seriously because I think
in her life that we're you know I feel
like I always deserve more I feel like
you know the world isn't recognizing my
genius and my greatness we know that is
narcissism
no no imposter syndrome is complete
narcissism
I actually think our imposter syndrome
is narcissism because you're so focused
on your [ __ ] self
well self-hatred is narcissism because
you're so important you still think that
you're more special like you hate
yourself more than anyone else like you
are worse than everyone else that you're
still seeing yourself as more special
I'm better than everyone why don't they
give me my recognition yeah that's nice
but I get like this self-hatred you're
still saying like I'm it's I focus so to
me narcissism isn't just being a
egomaniac to me narcissism is also
someone who's I focused it's always III
are yourself so I get that but like in
the term when when you doubt yourself
for like doing that feeling that's just
be like I feel like that positive
syndrome could be more about focus and
other people are not necessarily
yourself right that's why it's not
narcissist idealized image of
everybody's everybody else if I keep
bragging and trying to get like
recognition by you guys even though I
know like if I'm like I don't deserve
this much engine you guys know you do is
that I feel good about it that what does
that term you're fishing for compliments
yeah I feel like being artsy but if
you're just internally doing that to
yourself and it's not like coming out to
anyone else is that just a little self
esteem this is all self esteem you don't
feel like you deserve it yeah okay
that's nice too
have you guys ever experienced this
though yes all the time you did it now
yeah all the time because well I mean I
have to read a lot of books and you work
you should always be working on yourself
so I feel like this is something that
I've worked on a lot but I think part of
it is because of the lack of
certification for the things
we do in our industry we're like I
dropped out of college to pursue
entertainment well college you get a
degree it's like something that you say
like look at me I went to four years of
schooling and like here's a certificate
there's a physical tangible thing that
says I'm qualified okay but when you
drop out of college even if you have all
the experience in the world in your
field if there is no physical
certification or you can't point to
things and say like I'm an expert
because look at this and I got
recognized here or whatever you don't
have a form of validation that like the
world can see and so you almost I know
for this is just from personal
experience like it's almost like I felt
like I kept having to work to like prove
myself because I'm trying to prove it to
myself almost because there's no like
thing that says look I'm qualified I
just can only only have experience you
know that works for you it's a motivator
it is a motivator but it's also gets me
really depressed because I'm like wait
am I am I qualified or motivated by
other people's approval not because you
yourself wants to change the game and do
you know no it's just a part of it more
like I hear I have something that I
think would really help the world but am
I qualified to help them it might
qualify it till I give that advice out
and like so when I'm sharing it I'm like
this feels right this feels like purpose
but then it's in the aftermath where I'm
like we are it was I even supposed to do
that like was I supposed to give that
knowledge out or maybe I shouldn't have
trained more or maybe I should have done
over this thing over here and what if
I'm wrong that's all in my head yeah
it's then that's what this whole thing
is is that it's like being scared that
maybe I did maybe I [ __ ] up somehow
maybe I gave the wrong advice or maybe
I'm not supposed to be in this position
of being able to influence other people
or like tell people that the that like
this is what worked for me maybe you can
work for you sure but that's also
something that can't happen nobody can
ever get perfect I know I know you know
that yeah but that's that's part of what
I'm talking about is like it there is no
perfect advice there is no perfect I got
hey read this book in your say sometimes
people have the confidence where they
feel qualified because they have a
tangible thing like they're they're like
well I have a PhD after my name I have
you know MD or whatever have
certifications so they feel it almost
has that that power that feeling that
empowerment that you are qualified to do
the things you're doing yeah because
it's built into it right so if for me
personally since I didn't have any
qualifications or like something solid
that and it really isn't something made
up by society - but like because I
didn't have that thing that's recognized
by society I always just felt this like
maybe I'm not supposed to yeah it's just
a field that you chose to because that
doesn't it comes along with you don't
get those accolades until you're
standing on a stage somewhere getting
handed in a [ __ ] award exam it's not
even about the award or the accolade
it's just about like being able to say
I'm like qualified yeah well you are I
know I know but I know that now like
have you ever saw it in a way where it's
like the system is faulty and I'm just
showing and exposing how much it sucks
absolutely I read so many biographies
and most successful people drop out or
like a lot of billionaires dropped out
of college they figured out how to do it
in a smarter way that where they're
working like they were smart or not and
we're not hating on college [ __ ]
yourselves we're talking about we're
talking about our field does not come
with a certificate that says you can't
do this you can get a certificate after
in problem Olympics and I've got to get
disclaimer is on disclaimers on
disclaimer is about everything well but
it's all it's how you frame it right and
in also it's who you're speaking to
because you can't expect everyone to
understand you have you have heard of
the zone of proximal development no so
depending on what someone's level of
consciousness is and education you have
to speak to them differently here's a
for example you're not gonna speak to a
three-year-old like a scholar right so
you have to and we have a huge age range
and people of intellectual like not like
like understanding yeah and so we can't
generalize to the point where everyone
understands so you're sometimes not
speaking to the whole audience it might
be nice and then you're gonna anger like
80% because you're also talking from a
place of experience because you have
create successful businesses and stuff
like that so when you do tell them like
hey you don't need this for them they're
like they don't see you usually oh you
just dropped out you got lucky you did
this
and then they just don't see the other
side well you're trying to come to them
like hey you don't really need this
right and there are a lot of trial Hardy
people who get in the comments and they
try to talk like we're trying to
advocate for getting away from college
and they try to go like everyone please
go to college don't listen to these
people they're gonna ruin your lives and
I'm like oh my god
that's not what we're [ __ ] talking
about but that's they choose to see this
like what we're saying as adversarial to
what they're about no I mean I'm not
against the nine-to-five I'm not against
the college I'm just telling when I
usually say this it's like know yourself
and align yourself with the right things
that you want out of life college isn't
for everyone but at the same time it's
now become a huge racket college is a
there's a money-grabbing system and
people are leaving with huge [ __ ]
loans yeah and if you're gonna get in
debt if you're gonna have all that stuff
you might as well be doing something
that you want to do FN money I also feel
like like we talked a lot about this
industry and like it's hard it's a lot
harder to gain that kind of value
because it's not built into this
industry right you don't have the degree
you don't have whatever but people still
have this this imposter syndrome even
with a normal job right they have their
college degree they have a their career
they've been working that in their
career for like 10 years even and people
still feel like they they didn't earn it
like how do you what kind of advice
would you give to these people like even
though they've been working in their
career for 10 years keep doing what
you're doing success well they could
feel like they got their job because of
that one instance in life which is true
like anything that happens to any of us
is because of that one thing that
happened and then I was in one other
thing to happen yet and they feel like
that one thing that happened was maybe
because of luck but you know everything
is kind of a little bit like luck is
where preparation meets opportunity
yeah yeah and look around you everybody
[ __ ] up all the time and like Disney
just completely [ __ ] up Star Wars like
they made the less money on the third
movie than they made everyone gets lucky
too right it's not all by yourself
you're all merit like some people you
have great parents that help you you
hope you find the way you have family
members or whatever I mean you know why
do people expect everything to be done
all by themselves
that's the American mindset Yeah right
we're talking about impostor son or two
I've been reading a lot about perceived
expertise and like I also study the
opposite like how you're saying you're
the opposite of imposter syndrome I
study people that like I noticed that
they aren't qualified at all but they
perceive themselves as qualified and
they brand themselves that way and
people buy into that and it doesn't
matter that they're not qualified and I
always thought that was so crazy like I
look at them and go what a fraud not you
but like people thought all the time but
I don't but I've seen other people that
are broken I think you're a fraud yeah
like there's this one person in my life
who was broke as [ __ ] always complaining
about money but to the public she talks
about how ball and she is and she's
always like trying to flex up yeah it's
nuts bro and then everybody in her
comment section is like damn I want to
be like you like you got that fallen
lifestyle so but behind the scenes she's
always complaining about how broke she
and so I'm like damn see I see the
behind the scenes and I'm like I never
want to be like that and then it makes
me really like am i doing anything that
I'm like am I not being 100 and like it
almost like yeah it makes you really 8
yourself and that's why I feel like I
that's also like she's just being fake
right that it's a little bit more
different opposite of imposter syndrome
because she like puts out this image of
her being like this totally an imposter
right
Vico like she's awesome
everyone's buying into that so like is
am I like doing anything imposter
because I don't want to be that one oh I
don't want me know what you're doing and
you're sure of yourself then you don't
guess that and you can focus more on the
work that you want to do and give out to
them by the way this is all like years
ago
I don't feel this way now this is like
when I talk about depression it's like
after I have a better understanding of
it I can lose backing in retrospect oh
yeah I went through yes it's out like no
currently right now I am very happy with
where I'm at and like very like I feel
very solid about it but nobody but it
took years to get there nobody who's
wildly [ __ ] successful feels the
security of knowing that their name is
enough and like they made it right for
example everyone's
documentary now but Michael Jordan I
haven't gotten to watch it yet but I
know that Michael Jordan used to
practice every [ __ ] single day like
like during the season like he used to
he used to drive into the court and he
would be there early and he's working on
his game why he's Michael Jordan he's
arrived everyone you've already won
championships why the best already why
because he's not good enough
same with Kobe after a game he would
practice after a champion game like
you're good so instead of celebrating
he's practicing so no matter who you are
you you are our culture is built like
you said where it's like built pull
yourself up by your bootstraps on the
[ __ ] but you have to realize that these
people even the people who you see as
legends or special people they are
working their [ __ ] asses off and and
that's how they got to be legends and
how they get to be so they don't know
everything exactly and they still lose
games like we look at Michael Jordan's
record he lost a [ __ ] ton of games but
he won way the [ __ ] more so it doesn't
it's about what you're gonna do tomorrow
and and just trying to put your best
foot forward and or it could be like me
and just blame everything that's not
working right because you're supposed to
be there like I'm Muhammad Ali but it's
my body
[ __ ] yo body I mean look at Tom Brady
he's won more games than almost anybody
in the NFL and he's also lost more games
so it just says a lot like none of these
people are infallible like everyone's
not perfect no one is special no my
special
[Music]